this week the biden regime pushed
forward with a plan to make the border
crisis they created even worse they
nominated former tucson arizona chief of
police chris magnus to be the new head
of customs and border protection you
think things are bad now wait till this
guy's in charge
you believe we have a crisis at the
southern border yes or no does it really
matter whether we call it a a major
challenge a crisis a a big problem are
you saying there's not a crisis at the
border senator i no i don't think
they're
so no crisis it's all going completely
according to plan and actually in a sick
way that's true before the election
biden called for a surge at the border
now he's got one
what are they doing with those people
well we learned something about that
this week too they're flying them around
the country in the middle of the night
to dump them in communities out of sight
of the media
except the new york post caught them in
the act
we know from leaked border patrol
documents that at least 160 000 illegal
immigrants have been released into the
us with little to no supervision since
march the actual number is probably much
higher remember we now have a total of
1.7 million encounters
just this year here with the reaction
former acting ice director and fox news
contributor tom homan tom i saw you
talking about this the other the other
night um on the channel and you had some
really shocking um
data some numbers on the scale of the
problem that you you managed to get hold
of could you just tell us about that
again and and also your overall reaction
to what we've learned this week
well you got it right when you said the
162 000 wasn't the right number that was
a number of releases in two sectors from
march until the present the total border
patrol releases in the country steve are
over six hundred thousand
and that's right on their website about
uh title title eight title eighteen
actions
six hundred thousand and the number one
point seven another false another lie if
you look at borbacho's law enforcement
encounters it's actually yeah 1.9
1.9 because you're not telling the the
aliens that show up at a port of entry
and turn themselves over so it's
actually 1.9 encounters if you add to
that the 400 000 got aways you're
looking at 2.3 million this
administration has been lying from the
beginning they continue to lie the kind
the secretary went under oath last week
and says the borders close and secure
with 2.3 million it's ridiculous and you
stood on stage and del rio says to to
haitian migrants don't come you won't
succeed you'll be deported in meantime
fifteen thousand walking out the back
door released without court dates or
covet tests so this administration just
continues lying and they're not
apologetic the reason they move those
children middle night because again
they're lying to the american people
they don't want they don't want american
people to know what they're doing and
how many people they're releasing and
where they're releasing that in cities
that aren't expecting them this is this
i never see an administration outright
lie as much as this administration every
single day
it's absolutely right and it's so
shocking i want to go over your numbers
again because it's so staggering i mean
so you've got 2.3 million your total
number is that the numbers who are
showing up at the border and within that
you're saying what 600 000 are
coming in or what is it what's your
total just break down those numbers
again i didn't quite follow it
it's 1.7 border patrol encounters if you
add the port of entry encounters it's
1.9
people are counting people doing it the
right way coming the right way no no no
no no these are people that are that are
they come to the port of entry which is
the right way to claim asylum but these
are these are people making a product on
the asylum claim so 1.9 between the
border patrol 1.7 and ports of entry 1.9
right you add to that 400 000 got aways
and that's based on the numbers for the
past year and and chief rodney scott who
just returned verified 400 000. you know
you had 1.9 400 you got 2.3 million and
as far as it releases 600 000 releases
into this country you add to that the
hundred thousand got aways that's a
million a million illegal aliens in this
country emotional without court dates
that will never leave they're here to
stay
so i just again make sure i've
understood the 400 000 that term got
aways what's that that's someone that an
agent might see try and apprehend but
they literally get away is that what
that means no these are these are 400
000 got away they weren't arrested
that's based on accenture traffic camera
traffic drone traffic that the borbacho
couldn't respond to because 50 of them
are off the line working these
facilities i also want to mention
something else they claimed 192 000
encounters arrest by the border show
they said so that's a decrease from 212
000. no that the the number 120 92 000
is the right number arrested by border
patrol but the border numbers are still
continuing the client because when you
take 50 percent of the border patrol off
the line
that means less encounters but it means
more god ways so when they had the when
they had the situation in del rio
without 15 000 migrants at that time
when they pulled those resources over
there 224 miles of border
unguarded by any border patrol agent so
that so they have less encounters
because there's less agents on the line
but the number of galways continues to
climb
this administration is hiding the real
facts from the american people
of course and and they're totally i mean
just to hear you talk it's so
infuriating because it's all deliberate
and then you've got they put this guy in
who say there's no crisis when it's not
only obviously a crisis it's much worse
than what they're saying and it's a
crisis that they deliberately created
because of their open borders ideology
tom honestly thank god you're on this
it's really so important that you're
keeping an eye on it getting the real
information and such a strong voice we
really appreciate you as always uh
bringing that to us tonight great to see
you hey sean hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else